what was your first film where you
received a festival Laurel for it and
was it worth it was it worth entering
the the festival and and did you get
good feedback I mean let's shake things
up a little bit let's that's uh yeah
what was it worth it entering and all
the festival fees without naming any
names of course well we'll bleep them
out yeah why don't we start doing a
starter sorry to put you in the hot seat
we'll switch up sure I think my first
festival was my hometown Salem Oregon of
the Salem Film Festival for a student
short that I did that was really worth
it for me just because I was you know in
high school and they were playing
legitimate films at that festival so I
got to be there and experience it so
that it was a positive experience for me
great yeah okay the real Hollywood story
very good my first movie kings of the
evening did bang-up business with the
festival's open the number of them
closed a number of them won tons of
awards all over the country then I
started realizing what a business
festivals is that they exist on our work
it does it help I don't personally think
so unless you're in some of the bigger
festivals and people have told me that
you know unless you're in Sundance or
can or Telluride or something it's not
gonna do much for you in fact I remember
doing a panel similar to this I'm not
gonna say which festival or which city I
was in and the question came up what is
this award going to do for you for your
film and everyone gave their kind of
canned answers and got to me and I said
to honestly nothing that's the true
honest answer this this award will do
nothing it feels great feeds the ego
it's wonderful fills up shelf space but
no it will do nothing for the film and
that's the way I kind of feel about them
they're fun to do but I
okay fair enough thank you
houses that a home was International
Film Festival only one best film so that
was the first time I've entered and I
think I've done it one more time which
was for mercenaries didn't do anything
for me I was at the time I was already
in the business and working so actually
helping me did not help me in any way
so my first festival Laurel experience
was actually with my film now the queen
of Hollywood Boulevard I would have
premiered at the Boston underground Film
Festival funny enough we had action I
had somehow gotten distribution before
getting in any festivals so I had
already kind of like oh yeah I've
already kind of like Gardner around it
the festival process for me was a kind
of arduous one where it was a lot of
like big festivals being like we really
want your film and then not taking the
movie so it was it was pretty
soul-crushing
but um honestly what I actually had a
very good experience with the film at
the festival since it built a community
around the film and it's built
relationships and good press around it
and some bad press which you can use
this good press so yeah I think in the
end I would like a lot of my money back
from festival submissions because I paid
actors less than that but it was very
helpful in the end of the day to build a
community around the film and help it
release I guess but the difference on
this a little bit but the first Laurel
was our first film I give my life
freezer that's fre easy ' er which is
about this guy who killed his wife and
stuck her in the freezer because you
loved her so much you couldn't get rid
of her and we
actually invited to the Hamburg Film
Festival so they didn't cost me money
which international festivals is a
general rule you don't have to pay to
submit because they're funded by
governments usually don't pay any money
to submit to those but it was a great
experience because the once again
because it's international festival they
flew me out to Germany and they put me
up at a hotel I got to meet a bunch of
people who are all looking me like why
are you in this festival with your
little tiny movie but it was it was
actually a really good experience
how much did help that movie I don't
know though the festival that it
probably helped us the most was our
third film darker Mane's we got into the
it was the fifth year of a horror
festival in town called shriek fest and
we won best horror feature and that
basically set up like a slew of other
festival screenings I think we did like
23 more festivals and it did kind of
lead we did that for a year and it did
lead to us getting our first good
distribution deal for one of our movies
so it can work I understand what you
guys are saying especially Andrew I
think the biggest caveat now is the
whole festival thing is completely
changed most festivals do not program
their festival from submissions they did
safely take your submission fee and this
is the way it is most I would say 85% of
the slots our basically producers reps
have placed the movie or their studios
who already have distribution for their
movie and they're just using the
festival to promote the film they don't
need they are to have a release date I
mean quiet place great horror movie why
is it playing in South by Southwest when
it already has a distributor and a
release date
it's the 19 million dollar movie taking
a slot of some little indie that someone
killed themselves to do so the caveat to
I think submitting to festivals is don't
go crazy don't submit to too many talk
to filmmakers and they'll tell you which
ones actually will program their
festival based on the submissions
doesn't mean you'll get in but at least
it means you have a better shot of
getting in because 85% of the slots
aren't already taken before they even
open it to submissions so yeah one more
thing about laurel wreaths i was told by
a distributor and i don't know if you
guys have had any of the same
experiences but certain stores i was
told
actually don't like the DVDs having a
bunch of laurel wreaths on them because
it it makes it seem like an art film and
that's not necessarily their audience
their buyers so you can get all the
laurel wreaths you want and it's and
then in some cases the distributor
doesn't want to use them and we'll take
them off the DVD because it's not good
for business you know second that Andrew
because darker Mane's which got one best
horror feature the DVD distributor did
not want to put best horror feature from
shriek fest on the DVD because he said
that they don't care it's about
festivals and I of course was like but
it's a horror festival it's not an art
festival but they still didn't want to
put it on so to andrew's point that's
really interesting because I would
imagine without mentioning the name it's
probably a large chain that piece might
doesn't get people health insurance
anyway so we'll skip over the name of it
but so knowing that you could actually
make money from your film how did they
want you to market it even though I
would think an art film would be great
those are the kind of films I love but
it sounds like that's not what sells so
maybe you can touch on how did the
distributor want you to make it appear
less sort of indie more there is no
appearance they just want the film to
speak for itself they want the cast to
speak for itself they hope that the
faces on the cover are recognizable
enough and we'll bring in an audience so
that's pretty much how no they didn't
want to market it as anything other than
this one you know it was a
african-american period drama so yeah it
just was what it was interesting okay
anybody else had something to add about
okay I kind of talked about my first
festival experience my high school short
but I've of course with mad genius had
the festival experience with my first
feature and we premiered in Fright Fest
in London we played in Austin and then
San Francisco and had you know really
pretty good responses there
and the festivals we don't use the
wreaths in our or the laurels in our
marketing the sales agent does use the
festivals when he's selling to
distributors as sort of like a you know
badge of honor but publicly we don't
necessarily market the festival laurels
okay so there's sort of a time and a
place to make the laurels be known I get
add one more thing on festivals which I
found really interesting maybe for the
first time on this one cuz we played
three so far is what I've been using
them for is it's free audience market
testing to find out what people get
really jazzed about the movie to help us
figure out the marketing because I can
tell from the Q&A s what people really
get excited about and I also kind of
flip the q and A's to the audience so
I've actually been able to get a lot of
mark free market research from the
festival audience that if I was putting
together you know a market screening
test of the movie would cost me a lot of
money so that's a little side benefit
that you can do to add festivals which
is not gonna help you know yes sir
distribution but at least gives you an
idea of what you've got because as a
filmmaker obviously you can't see the
forest for the trees sometimes and you
know movies are for other people to
enjoy wat so it's kind of important to
know what their reaction is a great
point so you can hear when they laugh or
if something just falls flat and you're
like oh I thought people would love that
well yeah and a scary horror movie you
can tell from audience reactions a lot
what scares what doesn't but also really
from the QA is great because you can
really from the questions people are
asking you can get a very good sense of
what people get really we're really
interested in and fascinated about in
the movie and and if something didn't
work you'll find that out too cuz you'll
get a lot of questions like I dunno
speaking of which does anyone have a
question in terms of turning it to the
audience for QA anybody have any
questions about festivals or okay
curious have you ever asked a festival
to wave festival fees and how was it
received I'm sensing there's a story
there right
okay yeah I would I would second the
notion that a lot of festival fees are
not worth it I would really focus you
know on the festivals that like do your
research as to which ones you think are
going to accept you and will benefit you
and that you want to be a part of and
all the other ones are not worth it
I I definitely have done a shotgun
approach in the past you know and found
that that wasn't really worth it and
then what I found also is that by
getting into one that's decent then you
start to get invited to others and when
that takes place then there is no fee
and there's you know you you just know
you're in and that's so it's kind of
about getting like a the first good one
can really have a ripple effect and I
don't totally mean to knock festivals I
mean if it's a short film and you're not
going to rent a huge theater and it's a
great night for you and your cast and
crew to go out and you know then have
drinks afterwards or whatever then it
sounds like it's worth it but as a rule
to try to continually launch a film
that's that's kind of where I was was
going and and hoping to hear from it it
sounds like well I think you just know
that if you're if you're gonna do it
have a targeted approach I mean I know
some people who are like I'm submitting
to fifty festivals that I'm like what
are you doing and so much money you
could use some of that money from
marketing buy some online ads or you
know market better marketing materials
or whatever I mean so I think yeah what
you said like Target it did you have
something to say yes so yeah I got to a
point where I was my film was being
invited by a lot of festivals and then I
started noticing that I was opening
night or closing night and then when the
awards would come up some film that I
honestly really thought was awful would
win best of the festival and and I and I
would just walk away to school I don't
understand this I'm and why is my film
and it was a well your honors being the
opening or the closing film and it's
like I don't know what to do with that I
don't know what I can't I can't write an
essay on a post
explaining that I can't you know I don't
know what to do so by the last one and
maybe a little bit of a jerk move but I
was invited to yet another one and I
said well I'll come if you give me an
award and they did okay they made up an
award special for me and made a
presentation and they did what festival
is that in and look there were some
great festival experiences and so I'm
not gonna say they're all they all use
the film great some are not so great
some are a lot of fun somewhere not so
fun somewhere very kind in giving so
yeah I can't knock them because we had a
good time and it gave us a lot of stuff
to talk about a lot of PR